for the new channel obviously your
guys's streams on each other's on your
own respective channels are really big
um it's going to be is it going to be
streaming [__] or is it going to
essentially be everything just like you
guys are getting the space we're gonna
have streaming stuff over there we're
gonna have original content any ideas
that come to mind we're going to be
signing Talent we're going to be doing
everything we're supposed to do yeah but
we also gonna be taking our [__] time
too we're not going to be sitting out
here rushing just throwing [__] on
camera and just doing anything you know
what I'm saying like we'll take our time
with what we got right now then we'll
just add gradually and then you'll just
see the growth and the evolution and
everything like it's no need for us to
go in here and rush but we definitely
gonna come with it you know what I'm
saying because we you know we learn from
the best and just looking around you
feel me and having that free spirit and
free mind to go out and try to try new
[__] and you know and have it work like
we've seen the ins and out of all of
that [__] and that's just that was a
great experience in itself though so we
we got the sauce you know what I'm
saying just gonna implement it I
definitely think y'all had the sauce in
that building like y'all kind of brought
the flavor over there you know what I'm
saying like Michelle brought the
substance I feel like you can correct me
if I'm wrong but it felt like a lot of
artists had stopped like wanting to go
over there but it kind of felt like
because you were there they would still
go over there is that is that safe to
say yeah I fought hard like I'm telling
people like bro come [__] me man
listen I don't want to come over man
that's for me yeah it's a good look for
me and then you get certain individuals
that's coming through them doors and
upon using his resources he's been
trying to get you over there for almost
two years he's like ah you know what I'm
saying so you ain't doing no interviews
right now [__] no
I'm at the Calabasas Country Club yeah
no but like you know I go to the club
and the artists be like bro they
watching it right they just like oh I
don't want to be involved with their
platform and then you know certain
people like Wiz come through hard I'm
gonna do this for you right you know
what I mean and pum hey Mozzy come on
there's certain individuals like okay we
made it to where it was it was cool and
I feel like it got this identity back as
far as for a sec and then the identity
became all the drama man yeah how do you
guys prevent that same [__] from
happening
with your foreign
but you know
initially when drama happens it's it's
not on us you know I'm saying that it's
not our job to post clips and post the
videos and go hard with it like we're
not in control of that so if drama
happens and if you putting it out that
has nothing to do with us you know I'm
saying it can stay internally it can
stay in-house but if you choose to put
it out as a platform as a company that's
on you you know what I'm saying we
didn't ask nobody to do that we don't
control the clip channel the main
channel the Instagram we're not for sure
any of that [__] so who's really
controlling the narrative you know what
I'm saying like who's controlling what's
going on and what you guys see as far as
the drama and that really was like no on
camera drama like our pod at the end of
the day has never beefed or argued not
one [__] time you know what I'm
saying in the other part that left uh
which was disconnected they've never had
any drama at all either so all that
other [__] was just [__] that didn't
have anything to do with us and we'll
just speak on it you know what I'm
saying so those clips will arrive from
that [__] you know what I'm saying and
videos are right from that [__] still
like we wasn't in control of putting
that out so we y'all written and the
people really can't blame us for that
[__] so you know what I'm saying and two
is you you can't win for lose because if
you don't speak about it oh you're
scared you ain't speaking about it or
your PC and when you do speak about it
oh you're a messy you shouldn't do that
so it's like people don't know what they
want